the subtlety of art depends on the
artist's ability to deliver their
message in a single brushstroke
with 50 years of experience studying and
practicing traditional korean
calligraphy
artist hau hoyte has subtly transformed
hangul into a universal language by
blending emotion and calligraphy into a
new art form called ebiography
[Music]
[Music]
in 2005 master ha created mammography
he begins his process by finding
inspiration in nature
and also in the subtleties of korean
culture
master ha envisions which characters
he'll use to tell his story and channels
his emotions into his
[Music]
brush master hall uses hanji raging in
size often over six feet in length
using his enormous horse hair brush
master ha quickly moves from one side to
the other
creating a giant picture comprised of
lines both big and small
the messages master ha creates are
designed to read as korean letters but
subtly appear as images that can be
universally understood outside of korean
culture in this piece master hall writes
the korean word for seed looking deeper
at the piece the letters subtly
transform into a landscape with trees
and plants
each of master has works combines
letters and imagery that represent
beauty korean and western traditions and
the power of nature
without speaking master ha is able to
communicate these experiences to his
audiences as a sensual and emotional
form of art
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you